is a god who has power to conquer all
other gods and he tells you and me
because of that thou shalt have no other
gods before me because he delivered the
israelites from egyptian bondage they
had to work seven days a week
and god spake all these words saying
i am the law thy god
which have brought thee out of the land
of egypt
out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any graven
image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them
for i the lord thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
and showing mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord
thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord thy god
in it
thou shalt not do
any work thou not thy son nor thy
daughter
thy man's servant not i made servant not
a cattle not a stranger that is within
thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it
honor thy father and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery
thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant nor his maidservant
nor his orcs nor his ass nor
anything
that is thy neighbors
i am very grateful to god for the
pleasure the privilege and the holy
honor
of bringing his word to you today
and my prayer is that the holy spirit
whom the bible calls the spirit of truth
will open your minds to receive thus
said the lord
i will try within my power to give you
only thus saith the lord and keep all of
my opinions to myself because opinions
do not save when jesus prayed to his
father in john 17 verse 17 he said
sanctify them through thy truth
thy word is truth
this is the sanctifying agent not the
opinion of the preacher
while i'm speaking there are a few
things i'd like you to do for me one
wherever you are
please preserve reverence as we worship
god through the spoken word
number two
while i'm speaking pray for me and ask
god to put his words in my mouth and ask
god to open your minds to understand his
word
and i pray that you will think as you
listen always think
when listening to the word of god or to
anything for that matter let me offer a
word of prayer for the involvement of
the spirit of god
our father in heaven we come to you in
the name of jesus
the name of the one who said let there
be light
the name of the one who said let my
people go
the name of the one who said i am the
resurrection and the life
the name of the one who said o death
where is thy sting o grave where is thy
victory the name of the one who said i
and my father are one
in the name of jesus christ their god
put your words in my mouth
grant me the spirit the humility of
christ
give me simple language father
that those listening may understand the
truth as it is in jesus
bless all those who listening
touch them in a very special and
personal way if they have aches and
pains remove those aches and pains i
pray
and put a double blessing on the
children
now father
i commit myself to you use me for your
glory i pray
in jesus name
amen
our subject for today is simply
to know god
to know
god
genesis chapter 1 verse 1
says this
in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
god introduces himself to the human
family as
creator not savior as creator not as the
host the the general of the host of
heaven but as a creator and this
therefore must always be significant
regardless of what we study from genesis
to revelation we begin on the solid
platform
that god is the creator of heaven and
earth and so the bible says in the
beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
in exodus chapter 20 reading from verse
1 the bible says and god speak all these
words saying i am the law thy god which
have brought thee out of the land of
egypt out of the house of bondage now
the god of genesis 1 1
is the god of exodus 20 1-2 let me say
that again the god of genesis 1 1
who said of whom it is said in the
beginning god created the heaven and the
earth this is the same god
of whom it is said and god spake all
these words saying
i am the law thy god which have brought
thee out of the land of egypt out of the
house of bondage and so we have
creator in genesis 1 1
what we have in exodus 20 1 and 2 is
savior
the savior is the creator the creator is
the savior now if you read exodus 20
from verse 8 the bible says
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord thy god in it thou shalt not
do any work thou not thy son nor thy
daughter thy man's servant not thy made
servant nor thy cattle nor thy stranger
that is within thy gates for in six days
the lord made heaven and earth which
lord the lord of verse 1 and god spake
all these words saying verse still i am
the law of thy god
this is the same person in x in genesis
1 verse 1.
the creator
is the same person who delivered the
israelites out of egypt
only the creator could have come
as savior
to know god is our subject we're
learning that our savior
is creator of heaven and earth the bible
says of god in him we live and move and
have our being acts 17 verse 28 the
creator of genesis 1 1
is the one who gives you life it is he
who allows you to hear it is he who
allows you to see it is he
it is he who sends the rain to water
your plants it is he who sends the
sunshine for them to grow it is he the
creator of heaven and earth who is also
the savior now i want you to focus on
exodus 20 1 and 2 again
but before i do that let me offer
another prayer father continue to be
with me i pray
possess me completely dear god in jesus
name amen
and god speak all these words saying i
am the lord thy god which have brought
thee out of the land of egypt out of the
house of bondage now god doesn't say i
am the law of thy god that created
heaven and earth he wants to be more
immediate he wants to be more if i may
use the word
contemporary and so he refers them not
to what he did uh maybe 1500 years
before they were created or before they
came into existence he is talking about
what he had done for them
very very recently in bringing them out
of egypt and so he says i am the law of
thy god which have brought thee out of
the land of egypt out of the house of
bondage now how did god do that what
does god mean when he said i am the god
that brought you out of egypt
god sent moses and aaron
let my people go exodus 5 1-2
pharaoh said who is the lord
that i shall hear his voice or heed his
voice or listen to his voice and let
israel go i know not the lord and i will
not let israel go now when pharaoh said
that god had to in a certain sense
introduce himself to pharaoh
a similar thing occurred with
nebuchadnezzar in daniel chapter 3
nebuchadnezzar said who is that god that
shall deliver you out of my hand daniel
3 15 nebuchadnezzar knew no power above
himself pharaoh knew no power above
himself god has to introduce himself to
pharaoh as a powerful god that
transcended pharaoh and all the gods of
egypt as he demonstrated hundreds of
years later to nebuchadnezzar
when pharaoh refused to let the
israelites go god sent ten plagues
plague number one
he turned the river of nile and all
sources of water into blood
plague number two he brought frogs upon
the land three he brought lice
four he brought flies
five he brought moraine on the cattle
the horses the asses the sheep the oxen
the the camels he brought moraine on the
livestock of egypt then he brought boils
then he brought locusts then he brought
a terrible darkness then of course the
final and the most devastating plague of
all god destroyed all the firstborn of
egypt of human beings
and of animals
now let me say quickly on god's behalf
god never wanted to send any plague
if pharaoh had listened to god when
moses and aaron spoke to him there would
have been no necessity for god to send
the plagues
after pharaoh refused to listen
after sending the first plague if
pharaoh had listened the other nine
plagues would not have come what i'm
trying to say is this it is never god's
will that he inflicts suffering on
anyone god inflicts suffering sometimes
in order to open our eyes and to wake us
up to show us that the life of
disobedience and stubbornness is a life
from which we ought to turn and so god
ended up having to send ten plagues upon
pharaoh
there's something else to keep in mind
the plagues attacked the gods of egypt
the river nile was a very important god
to the egyptians
they're the frog
flies no dogs cats birds hippopotamus
hyena you name it the crocodile they
were all gods and of course the sun god
which was defeated in the sense that god
made a terrible darkness for three days
and they could not see the sun in
sending his plagues god demonstrated his
power over all the gods of egypt the
gods upon whom the egyptians including
pharaoh depended
when god says therefore i am the lord
thy god which have brought thee out of
the land of egypt out of the house of
bondage god is telling us as he told the
israelites in the wilderness
i am the god that demonstrated my power
over all the gods of egypt not over one
god of egypt over all the gods of egypt
or the pantheon
all the gods of egypt god demonstrated
his power what's the lesson for us as it
was for the israelites you need not fear
any other so-called god i am the
all-powerful god and there is no god
that can stand before me and so god is
telling the israelites i am the lord thy
god
i am the conquering god i am the one
that demonstrated my superior power over
pharaoh who had enslaved you i am the
one who set you free
our subject to know god you and i need
to understand and remind ourselves daily
through exposure to god's word that the
god we serve is a god of power that
exceeds the power of all earthly powers
combined
in proverbs 21 verse 1.
proverbs 21 verse 1 the bible says the
king's heart
is in the hand of the lord
as the rivers of water he turneth it
with us so ever he will the heart of the
king
now we have two people in that verse
the king
we have the lord
the king represents the most powerful
earthly ruler
god is the most powerful person in the
universe and what god is saying i can
take the heart or the mind of the most
powerful man on earth or personal and
turn that person's heart on mind in any
direction i chose because there is no
power on earth that can stand up to the
power of god and so god tells the
israelites i am the all-conquering god
that delivered you
from pharaoh that delivered you from a
life of bondage we need to know who god
is and so before god tells the
israelites obey me have no other gods
before me do not worship idols do not
take my name in vain keep the sabbath
holy honor your parents do not kill do
not commit adultery do not steal do not
bear false witness do not covet before
he gives them a list of do nots
he tells them
understand clearly who is talking to you
you need to understand who is telling
you to keep the sabbath holy
it is i
who conquered pharaoh
and all his gods
there is something else god is telling
the israelites
and is telling you and me right now
when i ask you
to obey my commandments
in that request is a promise
of power to obey let me say that
differently
god is telling the israelites the power
i demonstrated to deliver you from the
bondage of egypt is the very same power
i will make available to you now to
serve me instead of being pharaoh you
see all human beings must serve one
person or the next
i'll say that again every human being
serves one power of the next
you and i either serve god or we serve
the devil
romans 6 16 know ye not that to whom ye
yield yourselves servants to obey his
servants er to whom you obey
you and i must obey one or the other
it's either god or satan and those
choices you cannot add to those choices
this goes all the way back to heaven
when the angels had to decide to listen
to lucifer or to listen to god
it was shown in the garden of eden when
god said thou shalt die the devil said
ye shall not surely die adam and eve had
a choice shall i listen to god or shall
i listen to satan
and so god tells the israelites i have
brought you out you served pharaoh by
force
now serve me
by choice
the power by which i delivered you from
egyptian bondage and spiritually
egyptian bondage represents bondage to
sin
pharaoh symbolize satan egypt the life
the land of sin
god's deliverance symbolizes spiritually
deliverance from
slavery and bondage to sin and god is
telling us as he told the israelites the
power whereby i delivered you from
egyptian bondage
is the same power i will use to enable
you to keep my commandments or to enable
you to serve me because to serve is to
obey
when the israelites served pharaoh they
obeyed him they had no choice
and our subject is to know god let me
say this again when the israelites were
serving pharaoh they had no choice
they could not decide to leave they had
to do whatever pharaoh said they had to
obey him so whether you and i serve god
or satan we have to obey we either obey
satan or god service is obedience a
servant serves by obeying not by
rebellion rebelling rebellion is not
service
god brought them from serving pharaoh
and asked them to serve him
god brought them from obeying pharaoh
and asked them to obey him and god
promised in the ten commandments the
power to obey
you and i need to understand that when
god tells us thou shalt not kill
in that command is the promise to avoid
killing because god has to be
responsible for our obedience in the
sense that what he asks us to do he must
empower us to do
i'll say that again repetition is an
effective tool of teaching so i'll
repeat
whatever god asks you and me to do
he must empower us to do
now when we sin we need no help from god
but in order to serve god we need help
from god and so when god says remember
the sabbath day to keep it holy if
you're considering observing god's holy
sabbath which is the seventh day the day
between good friday and easter sunday
then you need to understand believe
accept and yield your entire will to
this reality the god who tells you keep
the sabbath will make a way for you to
keep the sabbath the god who tells you
thou shalt not steal will
make aware for you to return that tithe
and that offering that you have been
withholding from god because you are
intimidated by your bills whatever god
asks us to do god empowers us to do and
that is particularly the case in the ten
commandments now why do i say that you
see the ten commandments represent a
divine
standard
no human being
of his own or her own can reach a divine
standard
no human being unaided can properly
observe a divine standard
thou shalt not kill
is a divine standard
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
is a divine standard observing sunday as
the sabbath is not a divine standard you
do not need god's help to do that
and i do not mean to offend but
sometimes the truth makes people
uncomfortable let me say it again
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
is a divine standard and requires divine
help observing sunday of the sabbath
which it is not is not a divine standard
and requires no divine help whatsoever
and i do not speak harshly i simply
speak directly
the ten commandments are a divine
standard they reflect
the very
character of god because god is love
the commandments express love the first
four love to god the next six love to
our fellow man and woman and so god is
the one who must enable us to obey his
commandments what have we learned about
god this god who said i am the law of
thy god which have brought thee out of
the land of egypt out of the house of
bondage we have discovered from the
bible that this is the same one of whom
it is said in genesis 1 1
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth
it was he of whom it is said and god
spake all these words saying i am the
law thy god which have brought thee out
of the land of egypt what have we
learned about this god we have learned
that god has power
immeasurably superior to the power of
all earthly gods and there's so many
gods running around this earth by the
way any god beside god is a man made god
let me say it again
apart from this god the father god the
son god the holy ghost
all the other gods people serve are man
made
the god we serve is not made
the god we serve made us
the other gods people serve they made
them
i shall say that again
listen carefully
the god of creation
made us
the gods we serve we made them
apart from the creator apart from this
there is no god and if anyone listening
to me is serving any other god you are
serving a god you made and so we have
learned that the creator the savior the
deliverer of the israelites from egypt
is a god who has power to conquer all
other gods and he tells you and me
because of that thou shalt have no other
gods before me because he delivered the
israelites from egyptian bondage they
had to work seven days a week
as a matter of fact when moses came to
pharaoh moses began a sabbath reform in
egypt and pharaoh complained you're
making the people rest that's why he
ordered them to find their own straw
moses began a sabbath reform pharaoh
said well since you've taken the day off
you perhaps need more work and so he
withdrew the straw and commanded them to
find their own straw sometimes obedience
to god requires sacrifice but the
egyptians had to work not egyptian the
israelites seven days a week god who
delivered them from that said rest one
day
and the god who delivered you from seven
days of work
will empower you to keep the commandment
that says
remember the sabbath keep it holy i need
to say that again the the israelites
work seven days a week in egypt they
were slaves
god delivered them and god tells them
now you work six rest one and i am the
one commanding you to rest one who am i
the one who delivered you from egyptian
bondage which was work round the clock
seven days a week
what have we learned about this god
the deliverer in bringing the israelites
out of egypt he was delivering his
creation in the sense god made humanity
god made life
when god saves you he is saving what is
his by creation
creation gives god the right to
intervene in your life when you invite
him
the israelites cried out to god exodus 3
verse 7. god heard their cry they cried
out to god and god accepted the cry he
accepted the invitation and he came and
delivered them
god was delivering his creation jesus
christ who died on calvary's cross and
who rose who is our savior he saves what
is his by creation and by saving us we
become his by salvation
my listening friend
i present to you today
god
our subject to know god
what god
the one who said
let there be light
what god
the one who said let my people go let me
be more specific when i say which god
jesus christ
to know god the only way to know god the
father is to know jesus christ
jesus said in john 14
verse 9
have i been so long time with you and
yet hast thou not known me philip
he that have seen me
have seen the father
in john 14 from verse 6 jesus says let
me pray again father continue to be with
me to god as i try to speak for you give
me the right words bless those listening
with understanding in jesus name i pray
amen
john 14 6
i am the way the truth and the life
no man cometh unto the father but by me
if he had known me you should have known
my father also
if he had known me he should have father
also the only way to know god the father
is to know jesus christ and so jesus
christ is the focus the center the
superstar of the bible from genesis 1 to
revelation 22. so when the bible tells
us and god said let there be light we're
listening to the voice of jesus christ
before he became human when you hear the
words blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs is the kingdom of heaven we're
listening to the voice of jesus christ
when we hear back in the old testament
let my people go we are listening to the
voice of jesus christ when we hear
remove thy shoes from off thy feet we're
listening to the voice of jesus christ
when we hear i will send the flood upon
the earth
we're listening to the voice
of god
the voice
of jesus christ
who was it who said let there be light
it was christ who said let my people go
it was christ and who tells you remember
the sabbath day to keep it holy
christ
whom you love so much
and who promises the power to obey
jesus christ and that promise is sealed
by his blood which he shared on calvary
in the garden of gethsemane and the shed
blood of jesus christ merely symbolizes
the giving up of his life
here's a god
who gives you life physical
here's a god who gives you life
spiritual
here's a god
who is able to conquer all other gods
so-called gods which means there is no
circumstance you can face no matter who
created it for you that god cannot bring
you through and he demonstrated that by
conquering all the gods of egypt here is
a god
who has the legal right to save why
because he's saving what he created
and there's a god
who came in your conditional mind
human being to understand what we go
through
that having understood
he can do something about it
our subject
to know god
god is a deliverer
god is a creator
god is an enabler
god is human and god is divine
when i say god god god i am referring
particularly
to the second member of the godhead
jesus christ
it was he who appeared to more toward
joseph when he dreamt genesis 28 verse
12 and he saw a ladder extending from
heaven to the earth and the bible says
the ladder touched heaven and it touched
earth
jesus explained in john 1 51 that that
represented the son of man
christ
the creator
the deliverer
christ the conqueror
he understands you
and he understands god
he can help
the only god who can help you
is christ
there are other gods running around the
bible talks about that psalm 115
jeremiah chapter 10 and other places
they cannot help
the god of heaven and earth
can help
the deliverer of the israelites from
egypt can help
he who conquered death
can help
to know god
is to know
that here is someone
who can cover you
comprehensively
here is someone who can defend you
against the worst of your enemies here
is someone who can prepare you for a
place in his kingdom and here is someone
who can enable you to so live your life
now that the life you live now which is
an expression of the very righteousness
of christ will qualify you for a place
in god's kingdom
when he comes
i appeal to you i urge you i call upon
you in the name of this same god jesus
christ in the name of the creator jesus
christ in the name of the deliverer of
the israelites from bondage jesus christ
in the name of the one who conquered all
the opposing egyptian forces and the
gods jesus christ in the name of the one
who said i am the resurrection and the
life i ask you in his name
give your life to him
recommit your life to him allow christ
to guide you and how does christ guide
how does god guide how does it create a
guide how does the delivery guide he
guides through thus saith the lord
that's why the bible says thy word is a
lamp unto my feet
and a light unto my path
give your life to christ
and the man or the woman who does that
will embark upon a life with no regrets
whatsoever apart from the regret that i
did not give my life to christ earlier
let's pray father in heaven we thank you
for your word
we thank you for the simplicity of your
word the abcs of the gospel are easy to
understand
and i pray father that those who listen
to the word will consider very seriously
giving their lives to christ or
recommitting their lives to christ
father do all you will do all you can to
move upon the hearts of those who are
stubborn those who are resisting their
father reach them somehow their god
because your word says of you you are
not willing that any should perish so do
all you can to save i pray bless all
those who listen their father and hasten
that day when the creator when the
deliverer when the redeemer will return
to take us home those of us who've
allowed him to direct our lives this is
my prayer from my heart in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching advent broadcast
network could you partner with abn to
reach many around the world
give us a hand with a financial support
these are ways you can send your support
1. cash app dollar sign advent broadcast
2. paypal info advent broadcast.net
on bottom of each video on facebook
there is a support button
or send an email to info
advent broadcast dot net
whatsapp number plus one three four six
three seven zero
five
or call us plus 1-346-370-5540
thank you for your support may the lord
bless you abundantly
you